unlv is hosting a nurse camp for high
school students interested in the field
the annual event was put on hold by the
pandemic last year
hector mejia shows us how it's inspiring
young teens to become nurses
we are at unlv's clinical simulation
center where high school students are
getting hands-on experience
in the nursing field it's a week-long
day camp all things nursing
in the great color t-shirts you see high
school students learning from unlv
nursing students
they're also getting a little taste of
the college life almost
40 teenagers in all including angelina
robles
from rancho high school this has helped
me
realize that oh this is actually fun you
know mercedes bryant graduated high
school this year
she's now on her way to the nursing
program at unlv
i want to help people i want to be a
trauma nurse
i like gory things i like excitement and
that's what i like to do i just don't
want like a boring office job and
nursing has a lot of stuff and
opportunities
this for example is the suture and
staple removal station where students
are learning how to remove them
this summer program started in 2019 but
was canceled by the pandemic the
following year
we need more nurses okay you know the
covet 19 pandemic
you know showed nurses on the front line
it really emphasized the importance of
nurses in our community
and we have a nursing shortage you know
we've done at unlv school of nursing
we've increased our enrollment
but we also want to increase our
engagement with the community if your
child is interested
there is room still to sign up for next
week there is a cost of 635 dollars the
university says
it handed out a limited number of
scholarships reporting near charleston
and shadow lane hector mejia
8 news now